look
gamers aren't perfect even the pros make
mistakes sometimes that leave us
scratching our heads and wondering how
they even survive for this long
and it's not just players either entire
tournaments can be derailed by a single
dumb decision
so today we wanted to rank those
mistakes here are the top 10
biggest screw-ups in esports history
opening up today's list is a rare league
of legends team kill from the 2017 world
championship cody's son loses his mind
by flashing into an entire team at the
end
up against an oh and four fanatic in the
group stage immortals just needed to
beat them
one time to knock them out of the
tournament but after a late game team
fight erupted in the bot lane
fnatic found the upper hand seeing his
mid laner go down
immortal's ad carry cody sun went for a
hero play
but things didn't exactly work out for
him they want this one the chain sport
on public not quite the blade color
range
and just barely missing onto that miata
but there's still more to be done they
look for the kill reckless going to come
in and brock's getting to the kill
spread on that one
and the flash bar coming out the
intersection betrays his teammate and
it's gonna be the age for fanatic
cody son loses his mind by flashing into
an entire team at the end
fnatic went on to win their next three
games to make it out of the group
including a tiebreaker against immortals
making this particular screw-up
sting just a little bit more
next on our list is arguably one of the
biggest disasters in esports history
2015's gaming paradise gaming paradise
was a tournament in slovenia originally
set to feature both dota 2 and cs go
but due to a slew of problems both in
and out of the to's control
only the cs go tournament happened but
it barely
happened beginning with the qualifiers
players flew into the country to find
out that the buses sent to pick them up
were late
with players waiting until 3am to get
into their hotel rooms
but the delays didn't end there the
qualifiers which were supposed to be
played
outside the next day were delayed due to
a random storm
[Applause]
but at the main event a few months later
things only got worse
the actual tournament didn't have good
pcs the streams were riddled with
technical issues and
oh yeah the police showed up to
confiscate players passports
because the tournament's financier
didn't actually pay for room and board
first bad thing that happened today one
of our
staff members from gaming rs approached
me and told me that
he can't get his passport and
i really didn't know what is happening
because
who doesn't want to give passports to to
to people because that's your personal
id there's a good reason why we never
got a gaming paradise too
coming in at number eight is an
embarrassing fail from myth
chad if we could press f to pay respects
rest in peace but
myth is one of the most popular fortnite
players in the world and at the game's
first lan tournament
everyone pegged him as a favorite i
think something that i'm
super like so the main feeling that i'm
feeling when i was like super anxious i
just want to get up there and just like
play like
never mind at this interview let me just
on there you know but during the
tournament
myth got a little too close to the edge
making a mistake that's gone down in
fortnite history he did like the the
last couple engagements he saw an
opportunity to take advantage
distraction oh my god myth just fell off
the map
smith just fell off the map did not
stick the landing
chad if we could press f to pay respects
rest in peace but
myth just fell off the map well based on
what he said earlier that's the one game
that he's going to lose in this heat
right
i guess the one thing that i just don't
want to do is i do fall damage i have a
record for doing that so
as long as i don't die to fall damage i
think i'm going to be pretty good you
know what i mean as long as i'm about to
fall down
taking number seven on our list is the
catastrophic warcraft 3 reforged launch
tournament
we have no breath of fire by the way it
is drunken haze so big miss chance on
these dragon hawks
and a disconnect
i'm going to assume thousand dropped but
i feel like moon was
on the way to holding this attack
wow warcraft 3 reforged was supposed to
be one of the biggest games of 2020.
instead it was a mess of bugs and broken
promises
these bugs were not only painful to sit
through but they also ruined the game
at the launch tournament thor zane was
about to beat moon the best warcraft 3
player of all time
but then got kicked out of the game
before he could win
twice you're benched
and looks like another drop just happens
oh wow it got so bad the tournament said
screw it and reverted the game back to
its 20 year old classic version
not a great look for a launch tournament
coming in at number six is the broken
meta that terrorized
world 2015. the dragon is still changing
the enemy 80 carry laura's got to be
careful
the dragon value is big on this one all
is well
there's a triple kill they're going for
four
for some reason ryan decided to
introduce a whole new type of champion
to the game before worlds
called juggernauts reworking a few
champs to fit the new class
this ended up making darius and
mordekaiser pretty broken
a big knockback and that's the kill of
the morgana azir goes down as well but
the dunks are coming through
a double kill for a balls a triple kill
at a broken gangplank and a shallow
jungle pool to the meta and
worlds that year became a complete [ __ ]
show
thankfully this mess taught riot not to
completely change their game right
before the biggest tournament of the
year
coming in the halfway point on our list
today is a mess up from jensen at the
2017 lcs spring finals jensen didn't get
his zonias off didn't get his ultimate
off
he goes down in the critical fight one
game away from earning his first
domestic title
all jensen had to do was pop sonia's to
avoid dying
except he forgot to use it
[Applause]
far too low goes down this mistake not
only cost jensen a potential lcs title
but fans would continue to meme on him
for his mistake for
years even tsm bm'd him two years later
when he met them in the 2019
lcs spring finals and they hovered echo
though this time
jensen didn't make the same mistake
reverse sweeping tsm to win his first
lcs title and
for some more icing on that cake this
time it was a tsm player who made the
game losing blunder
no quick silver sash he is down
he is shut down what is he doing to
baron
in overwatch pulling a c9 is when a team
throws a map because they forgot to hop
on the objective
it's an embarrassing mistake and that's
why it's taking the number four spot on
our list
oh my god that was actually a c9
that is a big old c9
the origin of how c9 got attached to
this mistake stems all the way back to
ogn's old apex tournament
it's at this tournament where c9 forgot
to hop on the objective three times in a
row
yeah you heard me right three times
he's got the whole hog there's a pulse
bomb going in and a couple kills
mendo does get the one onto donghyun
going on to that and
it looks like afrika blue did they just
not touch the point i guess not
well that was a bit odd arhan's gonna
get taken out can't really do much about
that adam in trouble
mendo trying to run away but nobody's
out there you're kidding me again
what this is what's been so annoying in
the past but cloud9 with a great
position
there's a self-destruct though oh the
overtime
the overtime nobody was able to stay on
the point
truly a night that no one will forget
our number three entry goes to the
single most embarrassing screw-up
in fighting game history
so smart he couldn't burst because of
the super
but will she get dixie
oh my god what she had thought it was
over
and stood up and ogawa gave him no
remorse
that is exactly what happens do not
celebrate
oh my god ogawa calmly took the set
before washington even realized his
mistake
creating an unforgettable moment in evo
history that even reached traditional
sports television
uh ogawa won the semifinal match
eventually won the evo tournament
as i said he won the tournament yeah the
world's biggest mistake led him
win in the tournament can we keep that
celebration and go
back to it several times both
celebrations were good first
second one executive decision everyone
shut up
for the last 30 minutes of the show
we're running that on a loop
look we've all picked the wrong hero by
accident once
but have you ever had 34 million dollars
on the line when you misclicked
i don't think so i will say if i'm a
storm i'd love to be in a situation
where i'm against the lash
as they're gonna take the gyrocopter for
themselves so this is gonna be an
offlane boy
that is true something that we
definitely did not
expect alliance made a big draft oopsy
in an elimination match against rng at
the international 2019
but alliance brushed it off kept their
cool and tried to get the w despite this
unfortunate error oh my god
are you serious whatever did this just
happen
it's fine we gotta deal with it oh my
god
but unfortunately things didn't work out
for him
43 minutes into the game we have
ourselves a match where
both sides really they had their chance
right uh they had their game plans they
started to come online
obviously the disappointment here for
alliance
and topping off today's list is none
other than i buy power cs go match
fixing scandal
we've just had uh like five players one
gambling dude and uh the guy who runs
netcode cards
i've just all received the fact
right now i buy power were one of the
most exciting cs go teams in the early
days of the game
looking far and away like the best squad
in n a featuring burgeoning stars like
brax then known as swag
but all that hype came crashing down in
august 2014
when i buy power threw a match and it's
very weird to see steel opting over
skadoodle
i don't know if skadool's not feeling it
right now or what is going on but i buy
power is definitely not playing
like i buy power cutler's gonna peek out
and steal is right here with the cz
doesn't go for the shot he's gonna try
and get the flank off he's gonna have
two right there can they line up for him
what is he doing why did he hesitate so
much doesn't matter has the cc gets one
are they really just gonna wait the time
out right now is this really happening
oh skadoodle skadoodle why would
i don't understand jdm with a 3k that
will be a seventh round for netcode
guides but
you just watched your teammate get up
from jay i gotta say the entries are
looking a little weak from either power
along with the strats i mean they're
just doing very
basic things they're trying to just
fully attack these sites and
not really using any smokes or pop
flashes for the most part to their
advantage and it's very unlike them
the result of this threw up was the
permanent banning of the entire team
minus skadoodle a decision that some
feel was far
too harsh i think it's a very sad
history that he can't compete anymore
for me it's a little bit too harsh for
what happened and for being the first
time it
ever happened despite years of community
cries to unban these players i
power's mistake proved irreversible in
the eyes of valve
sure many of those players found new
homes invalorent last year but
this mistake robbed these guys who
looked to have very bright futures from
truly competing for years
and for that the buy power scandal is
the greatest and
most unfortunate esports screw up
alright folks that's our list if you
haven't done it already make sure to hit
that sub button subscribe to us and turn
on notifications and hey
if you've already done that grab a
friend and make them sub to the channel
because
i'm sure they'll appreciate the content
we're on our way to 2 million
subscribers and
every sub counts anyway thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week
one time in middle school i said
i guess i said salt and vinegar chips
and i said it i think i slurred it
because i have a lisp
and especially as a kid like i might i
just said things
bad anyway i said that and someone
thought i said sullivan
and for the rest of middle school people
called me sullivan my name is not
sullivan
no one else anyway they called me sully
or sullivan for three years it was
brutal
bullied incessantly because i [ __ ] up
the pronunciation of the word vinegar
anyway horrible kids are the worst don't
be a kid if you're a kid stop being a
kid kids are terrible